increasingly we're going to have a much
more demanding set of consumers in
healthcare that that's going I think to
result in and that's a good thing that's
going to result in the need for us to be
able to make transparent to them the
concrete outcomes of what it is we're
we're we're providing so for example if
a patient needs a liver transplant
they're going to be able to go online
and find out well who does the most
transplants who does the most
transplants from my particular condition
and what they should be able to find out
is what's the approximate range of costs
and what's the likelihood that I'm going
to get out of the hospital in a week two
weeks three weeks how many patients that
have this kind of a transplant need
another operate these are all the kinds
of things that we these are the outcomes
that we have to we have to be
accountable for and that we need to make
transparent to the public and I think
that's the right thing to do I mean I
think that the the our patients and if
we believe and we do at Mayo the Mayo
mantra which is the needs of the patient
come first they have to be fully
informed and we have to be held
accountable for the outcomes of the
things